what would you like to hear a rap about
self-help books cool any particular type
of self-help book that you want us to
focus on are you worried about giving
too much away what to do when you have a
very small penis what's doing a very
large penis you know it's cumbersome as
well isn't it well what I mean someone
else can help you on this one I mean
although that goes against the rules of
self-help doesn't it that someone can
come in there let's get a type of
self-help book I mean guys we have to
finish at some point so other area the
room helping out with this loving the
planet a self-help book okay cool yeah a
self-help book to encourage you to love
the planet what to do when you do not
love the planet I like it cool that's
the first suggestion we're gonna get
four more please don't take as long
giving me them as that did right
this kind of area here what do I wrap
that you've had so much thinking time
then I'll let me down over there Elon
Musk yeah that's obvious
come on be fun no accent area 51 gets J
all the time
he was in the bathroom how do you know
you were here got a little camera I'm
going to accept suggestions from
anywhere in the room that right come on
we need literally needs for wood selling
timeshares to hotel guests a pup book
for when you don't love the planet good
it's so far these are good you've made
up for it so far let's come let's get
three more mario kart can we have a
specific aspect of mario kart you on
that to focus on level one have you ever
played mario karta I'm not sure if
you're talking about you know like 50 cc
or Mario circuit okay level one of Mario
car that's what you said that's what
it's gonna be to wreck rainbow no sorry
that's definitely not level one may
that's impossible we can all agree the
snez versions the best one right um yeah
we've got Mario Kart format one no two
more having a wat on the garage floor
gain the oil off your garage floor from
the mg you pour yes this is it's been
worth the wait
okay there's only been one more but
we've got self-help books to teach you
how to love the planet selling
timeshares to hotel guests mario kart
but level 1 take an oil off your garage
floor from the mg you bought these are
amazing one final one this can be this
can be simple if you want right it
doesn't have to be tall those
how do you fly a hot air balloon what
did you say Princess Diana cool how do
you fly a hot air balloon when you are
Princess Diana that's the question
okay those are great suggestions we've
managed to pull it together this is
gonna be fun this lovely people of the
Comedy Cellar it's gonna be a freestyle
rap that has a rap made up on the spot
based in telling those suggestions it's
not rain down shut up where were you
when I needed you or the staff a
freestyle rap that's not written it's
not prepared and I'd be seen again and
do not worry who I'm anywhere near as
bad as you're expecting 30 year old
privately educated middle class white
boy to be let's do this if we can drop
the beat good sir let's get the shoes
were going for rizal I'm excited I'm
really excited to stir up got a goal
yeah I've got a quest I strive to sell
[ __ ] to hotel guests I'm standing there
and look sell for sure and I've got a
nice big viral well my clipboard I say
hello there
I've got wax in my hair hello sir do you
wanna buy a timeshare just a little bit
of money in the building you can sell it
later make a killing as a damn lie they
never will spell to speak with you until
you go to hell and then pass down the
progeny or your earlier relations
resurface God pay them
get it on the market if you buy it yeah
please don't start
it's just a scam it's really a swindle I
want to go like a big fire and he'll
burn show you when I press on the second
light Mario Kart get a rocket start
that's right when you see the guy in the
clouds hold that the lights among that
crowd maybe you ride a spouse or a
Princess Peach but which level are we on
I can't reach past level two so I am on
the easiest I call it level one it
doesn't exist bar may give up probably
it would involve vetoed cup toad circuit
Mario and the castle - not Rainbow Road
as a hassle to stay on the corners you
drop it up the edges it's horrible you
plummet into space from the ledges and
then they updated it for the Wii and
Nintendo switch and actually it's a
real-time sync amazing app on there I
tried badly like Princess Diana and
sorry that had to do that if you think
in your mind go straight back to 1997 in
Paree ornery the driver drove with glee
he was going too fast he felt all the
booze no seat belts in the back we used
but let me think about an alternate
timeline
Princess Diana could clear the land
mines from high here she's up and floats
on in a hot-air balloon drop across two
bombs to D charge other minefields in
the places to wear it lower and their
little kids faces
she was the chain yeah look at him
there's Dodi they would save those limbs
from the children sadly the press did
kill them that is what they say here a
move on
spill them the beans are mean and also
oil coming from my engine machine there
was a hole in it
Jesus I speak in an irate tone cuz this
oil leak was coming down the front who
the [ __ ] did did the guy who sold me the
MG [ __ ] is a fast car only got two
seats said it came a hundred percent
company it was repeated with turbo
charges I look inside I'm as angry as my
father gets when he watches the news I'm
in the garage I put down las a news
paper the only thing to absorb from the
floor if you don't like the plan that
you don't adore the earth she's a father
like James Lovelock said Gaia prophecy
hypothesis from the head you can get the
book you deserve a foreword written by
Grantham Berg to give you wit from the
library instead don't ask questions of
me look deep inside yourself we gotta
preserve the planet and preserve our
health like mentally yeah you're a
little well need to listen up and read
up about the self-help [ __ ] all that
stuff inside you if we don't stop using
all the fossil fuels we're gonna die
leaking oil like The Horizon deep water
or the car that you buy in that's breath
for the nice book you'll save the planet
get the polar bears
yeah
[Applause]